chairman of babber District Council and
I'll be chairing this meeting this
evening can I first remind you all of
some domestic
Arrangements toilets are situated
outside the meeting room opposite the
stairs cold water is available in the
breakout area also outside the meeting
room if the F fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by
following the fire exit signs and meet
on the ipswitch Town Football Club
training
pitch do not re-enter the building until
you are told it is safe to so
do please switch off all mobile phones
or turn them to
silent now then I'd like to remind every
everyone that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting Andor training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and the Press are not
lawfully
excluded
now then I think uh we'll move to the
agenda
yeah yeah I haven't got that bit on
there okay before I move to the agenda
I'd like to remind councilors that this
Council has agreed a debate not hate
motion therefore I will immediately
rebuke any member making a derogatory
remark about another counselor or
officer and will stop the meeting if
necessary as this will not be
tolerated also as per the
Constitution unless you have exceptional
circumstances please stand when
expressing a asking a question or
expressing um an opinion and
comment and also face the
chair and not the
auditorium thank you so now I will move
on to the agenda apologies for
absence thank you chair I have received
apologies from councilors Dowling mayy
Osborne Holt and
Parker thank you do we have any
Declaration of interests by any
counselor councelor
beer uh yes Madam chairman in item nine
I'm a member of sub Town
Council okay thank you duly noted thank
you
we now move on to
bc23 18 to confirm the accuracy of the
minutes of the meeting held on the 19th
of September
2023 and this is for accuracy
openly um does anybody have any issues
yes
counselor colleagues I did I didn't need
to leave the meeting at 8 o' I stayed
until the very end when you announced
the end
803 we will amend the minutes is that
acceptable yes thank you thank you
anyone
else okay so we're okay with the
accuracy can I have a proposal
please councelor Owen and a seconder
councelor Brin huren thank you all those
in
favor unanimous
yeah
now I'll now move on to I'm referring
you to paper
bc23
sl19 now this is for noting however
before
I offer it as for
noting I'd like to let everybody know
how disappointed I was because as
counselors we're busy trying to find
funds and things to help our residents
and our
businesses and
our I was the only
counselor at the funding fair in
Sudbury not a good Public
Image now I'd also like to take this
opportunity to thank if 50 for all the
support that you've given me cuz he has
given me a lot of support and a lot of
help um and I don't know if anybody
knows but or everybody does know but niy
is retiring at the end of next week yes
so we all wish you well in your
retirement yes vote of
[Applause]
thanks
okay
councelor Ward do you have any
announcements to
make thank you madam chairman yes I do
firstly I just um want to address uh
events of the weekend the weekend's
floods hit a number of our communities
badly and it has been a deeply
distressing time for many residents and
businesses who have seen property
damaged and lives disrupted the clean up
is now well underway and I know we will
all continue to do what we can to
support residents business businesses
and communities during this recovery
period additional Council staff have
been deployed in the worst affected
areas to assist with the cleanup areas
like Hadley long mford and parts of the
dead and Vil I spoke to one of our
public realm team just outside Hadley on
Saturday morning while visiting my own
parishes along the Bret and the store I
want to say a huge thank you to everyone
who was out there for our communities at
the weekend to our emergency services to
the council staff who have worked
tirelessly to our town and Parish
councils who did such a great job to the
local volunteers who helped their
neighbors family and friends and to you
our counselors and I know many of you
have been doing outstanding work
identifying issues in your communities
during the most critical times and
taking action I do however want to make
a special mention for councilors malvi
and nun who along with others were very
active in Long mford on Friday night
when Chad Brook burst its banks and
flooded several premises you really made
a difference so thank you both
it was a difficult weekend there's still
a lot of cleanup work to do but we
should recognize the Fantastic show of
community
Spirit moving on now along with our
chairman and councilors Carter and REE I
was invited to attend the official
opening of the new hasto housing
development in Stopman aland on 29th of
September this development of eight
homes on land that was part of a former
Middle School site has been named in
honor of Margaret Underwood who lived
her whole life in Village and dedicated
her 50-year career to education
educating children in and around Stopman
aland the houses have been built to H's
new build standard and we could all see
that this has delivered high quality and
energy efficient homes for those with
connections to the
Village the befriending scheme is a
charity based in sudur that supports
people with learning disabilities and
Mild mental health conditions it
provides friendship and learning
opportunities and runs a community farm
called the Red Rose Community Farm that
moved earlier this year from ashington
to a new bigger site in Lindsay Thai
babber provided £100,000 of sill funding
approved by cabinet last November to
help with this and I was delighted to be
invited to their open afternoon on the
30th of September they have achieved a
huge amount of less than a year to get
the farm up and running with workshops a
cafe po tunnels and accommodation for a
range of
animals I would like to remind everyone
that there is still time for people to
have their say on the council's future
Direction and priorities
we have outlined up the administration's
draft priorities but we made a
commitment to getting feedback from the
community are these priorities right
what else could we do and what have we
missed the survey will be live until the
15th of November and details can be
found on our website I'd encourage all
counselors to share this with their
networks posters and postcards have also
been created which you can share with
your
communities we're pleased to have
partnered with groundwork e to deliver
free and impartial expert expert advice
to help businesses and organizations
save energy reduce their emissions and
establish tailored decarbonization plans
this new net zero business advice
service will provide free support to
help businesses the voluntary sector and
other organizations to understand their
greenhouse gas emissions set a plan to
reduce these and exess grant funding to
implement carbon reduction actions more
information about The Net Zero business
advisor can be found on our
website finally we have joined forces
with suffs other district and B councils
to deliver a groundbreaking project to
improve life for landlords and tenants
in the private rented
sector safe suff renters is designed to
create a better understanding of the
pressures and problems in the sector and
to improve standards particularly in the
worst private rented homes in the area
to achieve this the project team will
consult widely with tenants landlords
and stakeholders in the county a
conference taking place at the
University of suffer in nip on the 3rd
of November is free for any landlord to
attend details are also available on our
website and similar conferences for
tenants and stakeholders will follow
thank you
chairman um item five is to receive
notification of petitions in accordance
with Council procedure
rules none received yes yeah okay
questions by the public in accordance
with Council procedure rules none
received questions by counselors in
accordance with Council procedure rules
received none
received although it is a way of asking
questions
bc23 sl20 overview and scrutiny
committee report now I'm going to invite
councelor McLaren to introduce her
report but I would suggest to everybody
that this report is for
noting okay councelor McLaren thank
you thank you madam chairman I'm very
pleased to present this report to
council uh it's pretty comprehensive we
are producing overview and scrutiny
reports every
quarter um now instead of annually uh
and I think it's pretty uh explanatory
but I'm happy to take any questions from
any members thank you
chair questions
anyone councelor
Riley than you madam chairman um first
I'd like to congratulate the chairman of
the on for a very comprehensive report
um and what I find interesting about
this report is that um we are there's a
re we've asked for a review of the
current cost of Baba and his resources
sorry page 22 uh third bullet point down
item
3.28 uh and we've asked that this be
undertaken and reported back to Joint o
and S now we asked for this in
July and correct me if I'm if my memory
is at fault but I don't recall that this
information was given to us or I
rephrase it to my memory this
information is still
outstanding
councilor Riley can I just check again
what you're saying
3.28 3.28 third bullet point down
following recommendation was made that a
review of the current costs of bber and
MAV resources and the potential impact
of further statutory responsibilities is
undertaken and reported back to the
Joint overview and scrutiny committee
and we are now you know what ju three
four months on um I don't recall receiv
this information and since we're here um
you know whether you have any idea when
we might do so and it's quite possible
that you know other people might have an
idea of when this information will come
forward right well obviously this is the
report on the annual
um levels of of um activity by the
community safety
partnership so if what I can promise you
I will go back to uh our support
Democratic support and I will find out
for you when we expect that but usually
the reports don't don't for this
particular committee don't come back all
that quickly that's all I can assure you
but I am happy on your behalf to uh
request an answer to your
question thank you coun McLaren this
item is for noting so we shall move on
to the next item which is
bc23
21 councilor Riley ex me mad
I but it g us an opportunity to ask the
chair of on and you know also the the
members of ons to might I suggest that
you could have written these questions
down and use the
question agenda item earlier on
there's no requirement for me to do so M
chairman I mean your suggestion I can
welcome but I chose not to do it because
then we would have had the necessary
answers for you
here okay well sorry I finished the
question are we now to
comment it's for noting only so you can
comment may I comment yes thank you very
much I like a
comment uh go back to page 22 first it
the S County Council head of community
safety advice that any additional
statutory responsibilities assigned to
the partnership result in increased
Financial costs and so
on why is it and this is a rhetorical
question that you know as soon as
there's more work to be done we go and
we require more staff because we should
be looking to using existing staff and
having our own
efficiencies it's no secret that when
you come to this building on Mondays or
Fridays you get the impression there's
more people on this maray Celeste than
there are in this building you know and
your point is and my point is we don't
need additional staff we need more we
need greater
productivity it it's counselor
Sally
than um I have a question on um the cost
of living um
report.
3.4 is the overview and scrutiny
committee satisfied with the answers
about um the support to Residents in
rural areas and residents who are unable
to access online services I know as
award member in a rural area I'm unaware
of any activity to actually get to
people might be very hard to reach and I
am concerned about this and I'm just
wondering whether the on committee are
concerned
to thank you chair thank you thank you
Council D um I'm a member of in a rural
area as well uh but we were satisfied at
the meeting that all um care was being
taken to reach all communities uh I feel
very strongly about my community and I
you can be reassured that the this the
committee actually felt that all was
been done there's been a lot of work
done by um the cost of living team and
uh Eliza who is the cost of living
coordinator has worked very hard she
only was appointed last October she has
worked extremely hard to bring together
all the efforts but if you would like to
apart from this meeting write to me with
your concerns quite happy to answer them
thank you thank you thank you very much
counselor and now councelor
mcra thank you chair um I'm always
conscious and with years of experience
in ons that there's a danger when we
look at these reports that we end up
repeating the process that overview and
scrutiny as opposed to have carried out
in the first place effectively we're
going over the same ground and I'm not
sure that's going to be very positive or
helpful to the members at the public at
large and members present at this
meeting any member can attend overview
and scrutiny and some do um some members
here are members of overview scrutiny
but they always have the option to raise
these points during that meeting and the
summary you see before you here is a
summary of what those members of
overview and scrutiny and others present
said at the time it's a statement of
what was done if you want to do it again
I suggest you go along to the next
one councelor councelor Riley you do
know that the number of questions you're
allowed that you get to ask is in my
gift thank
you so enjoy it while it
lasts I hope I it should
and so what's here is um because it was
deferred that we asked for an update on
the corks Lane development and my joke
for the night is of course that we
understand it's underwater at the moment
you know the
project no okay no um but I'm
told
well NS is not the appropriate body to
bring an update on this motor at this
moment in time if s particularly the S
is not the appropriate body what is you
know what is that we want public
information we want information to be
shared with all the counselors as to
what's going on and we're told no you
can't do it that's me a
comment um we've also asked for the
metrics on U Staffing and so we can look
at uh productivity confused here because
this is a report on the work that
on have just
completed it's not setting them the
agenda for their future
deliberations so if you want them to
consider your deliberations with regard
to items that they will be
scrutinizing then I would suggest that
you write the questions down and you
give them the opportunity of gathering
the facts for you thank you madam
chairman corks Lane has been on the
agenda I think three times in the last
three months so we're not getting
anywhere with it because we're told it's
not an
appropriate venue I'm going sharing this
with you so you all know what on is up
to and what problems it
[Music]
faces councelor McLaren thank you madam
chairman
councelor
Riley you are a member of overview and
scrutiny
committee you have repeatedly asked for
corks Lane just prior to this
meeting you being very disingenuous just
prior to this meeting I explained to you
when you left the overview and scrutiny
meeting yesterday without giving anybody
any reason why you were going
you were not present when I brought up
the subject of corks Lane with the
monitoring officer and our Democratic
Services
officer the other thing is that you are
a member of bber growth a director you
know more about Cork Lane than all of us
put together so I do find your
questioning questions rather difficult
but in relation to corks Lane I advised
you just 15 minutes
ago that we will be dealing with the
corks lane
report at a babber overview and scrutiny
committee meeting not a joint overview
and scrutiny committee meeting and that
will happen next month thank
you
coun
none of these items are contained within
the report we are considering even for
noting I think this is a waste of
time thank you now councilor Riley no
more questions we are moving
on
bc23 sl21 community of governance re
reviews for 2022 to
2023 I'd like to invite the interim
director Lord law and governance and
monitoring officer to introduce paper BC
2321 thank you chair through through you
chair you're welcome um the so the
community governance review for for book
began in uh March
2022 that was stage one in January of
20123 various decisions were made um
with regards to certain parishes and
numbers of C Etc so that was stage one
uh subury Town Council was the only one
that moved on to stage two and the
reason for it not not a decision being
made at that point was that um sub Town
Council were requesting um amalgamations
of wards which meant that there would be
uh boundary electoral boundary Ward
boundary electoral boundary and County
boundary changes uh that means that
you've got to go to wider consultation
and you've got to get the consent for
the um uh uh boundary commission uh for
England so what happened was uh in the
middle of um this year uh request was
made for uh counselors District
counselors County counselors the local
mp uh as well as sub Town Council to um
say and enlarge on their any
representations that they had at that
point the decision was made by sub Town
Council to not proceed with the
amalgamation of the wards but with the
number of counselors that they wanted in
certain so in Sudbury South West there
were sorry Sudbury
South sbur subury South in subury South
there were three counselors and the
request had been to to reduce that
number down to two and in Sudbury South
Southwest that's right Sudbury South
Southwest there were uh two counselors
and the request was to increase that
number to three now what that meant was
no overall change in the number of
councel still 16 councilors at sub toown
Council but there would be a change in
the number of councils in each of those
particular areas now what that meant is
that uh if that's the decision what that
what that means is that one Council
needs to stand down and there needs to
be a reelection for the other one to to
go that that's that's how it works
unfortunately so sub Town Council then
um moted that actually what we do this
in 2027 so those are the recommendations
that are before you they are draft
recommendations that they're not going
out to further
consultation um there is there is no
need to go to further consultation um
they are what they they are what they
are and and that's the uh the
recommendation could do for you today
and if there are any questions um with
with chair's Indulgence I'm happy to
answer before we have questions can I
have a proposer and a seconder
please or Rush councelor mcro I'm happy
toose CH thank you now then who has a
question councelor mcro do you have one
and then councelor register yeah
councelor Busby seconded
sorry yes I do have a question um would
subri Town Council not have the option
to co-opt a member who stood down for
the uh other ward in which case no
election would be necessary and they
wouldn't be re Ed to wait until
2027 I only ask because that is normal
practice within Parish councils who have
a vacancy and in this case they' be
creating a vacancy and they would have
the option to fulfill that particularly
when there are 16 members in
total
okay yes there would be that option um
but the other side of that is that you
still need a counselor to step
down okay councelor
register uh uh yeah I read and
understand and support this
recommendation um what I fail to
understand is why there was no change to
three other sub toown Council Wards
Hawkins Road Elman Hillside and St
Leonards all of which have small numbers
of uh return one counselor but for very
small numbers of electors uh on the vote
on The Electoral role uh would this be
achieved by What's um if he mentioned
about aalam amazing Wards and if and why
hasn't it happened why wasn't it
considered thanks thank you chair uh
that was they they weren't part of the
submissions the original submissions
were to amalgamate the wards and as I
said that would have meant um changing a
large uh three three small Wards into
one larger Ward but it would have meant
a change to the county bound boundary
the ward boundary and the necessary
electoral arrangements so the request
was let's not proceed with that we can
do that
later okay councilor beer I'm sorry
madam chairman just a comment that the
um officer just made um I represent uh
Hillside and El Road and you said this
may happen
later um hopefully that Ward will M as
it is is an important board it's I think
the largest of the three and I represent
it so I do have an interest thank
you perhaps I should clarify what I
meant by later that's that's the
decision for subre Town Council to make
a future governance review they may do
they may do or may not that's yes you
made it sound like they would that's all
I'm thank
you okay
do we need to enter into the debate
because I think we've had a bit of a
debate if coun
to councilors do you want to move
forward to a straight Vote or do you
want to debate it straight
vote thank you very
much thank you chair that vote is now
opening for councilors to cast their
vote
where
councelor Riley um you haven't cast your
vote four thank you thank
you chair that is 27 votes for that is
unanimous thank you very much moving on
then we've got item number 10 BC for
sl23 sl22 changes to the
Constitution again I would like to
invite the interim director Lauren
governance monitoring officer to
introduce the
paper thank you we're making you work
before you leave us thank you chair much
appreciated um there um the schedule of
amendments uh to the Constitution they
were um uh reasonably light touch um the
idea behind uh most of those amendments
was uh to have more um equality language
and inclusive language within the
Constitution um so a lot of the changes
were in relation to that uh also there
were certain um bits in the Constitution
where the links weren't working so
they've all been corrected and and
they're all being sorted out so there
are um so when you're in the
Constitution itself and you want to get
to a certain part of it with the link
they they all will be working shortly um
the other changes were in regard to the
um chair of overview in scrutiny and um
the clarification with regards to the
licensing licensing subcommittee and the
substitutions on those particular um
committees one part of the Constitution
said you could do it the other part said
you couldn't so we clarified that you
cannot substitute on licensing or or the
licensing
subcommittee um and then the other
change was the contract standing orders
um they new contract standing orders
they amended from the the previous ones
um not lost on me that actually there
are there's a few bits in there where
the language isn't inclusive and I will
endeavor to ensure that that
changes CH thank you very much thank you
now could I have a proposal please
Council a Ward and a second up councel
saw thank you very much now the
recommendations are 3.1 and
3.2 Council award propos yeah
thank you chairman yes I I would like to
propose this paper but with one um minor
Amendment uh actually and that is that
paragraph 4.2 um to I know we debated
this in the Constitution working group
but I've um since had discussions with
my colleagues and and we feel we want to
take it back to the original um uh
proposal that the Constitutional working
group started to debate so in the first
sentence of paragraph 4.2 I wish to
remove the word full and then only
retain the first sentence and remove the
rest of that paragraph So that 4.2 will
now read that the over obun scrutiny
committee chair is not appointed from
the administration group unless there is
a coalition Administration or standing
in for the chair keep it just at that
single sentence thank you
chairman council sord do you accept
councilor Ward suggestion yes thank you
very much councelor r
your question oh my question he yes
please um my question has your own
standing ordinance contract standing
orders I no is that contract standing
orders do not
include and the answer is why not the
question is why not any provision or
obligation on on the council's part to
inspect the contractor's work and hold
the contractors to account reason I say
this is because when we were at ons and
we looking at the homes and housing
strategy um for the current year and for
the year to come we were told that next
year we
would deliver quality repairs yes
planned work service yes remain standing
please sir sorry by holding thank you
our contractors to account and there is
nothing standing orders that indicate we
should be holding cont we will be
holding contractors to account when I
when I talked about this privately with
one of the officers I was told the
reason why it's on next year's um
ambition and not this year's is a
question of
resources in my previous existence here
uh I was told that we had Ambitions to
scrutinize and check one in three
contractors work
and I was told that in
actual actuality they did one in six I
was not give it was not given any
proportion of what is
being um what is being scrutinized and
so I would like the contract standing
orders at some point to make mention
that the contracts are to be
scrutinized so perhaps someone can tell
me
why the scrutinized ation of
contracts is not in the
[Music]
list the chief executive will answer for
you thank you chair and and I'll defer
to other colleagues who may tell me that
I'm wrong but I think it is in the list
um so 13.1 13.2
13.3 on pages can't read the text I
think it's 56 um sorry express contract
management yeah yeah 13.1 13.2 13
page
56 section
green eight sorry we don't get there 46
did you say 56 yeah 36 56 56 page 56 of
your
packs expressly talk about Performance
Management of contracts yeah including
the quality of the
work
thank you Mr trenia and thank you madam
chair thank
you now we've had questions
[Music]
anym
counselor
Rees yes I just like some clarification
please on Note
4.1 the Constitution has been amended to
update and use more equality compliant
and inclusive descriptors does that mean
that the descriptors at the moment are
not compliant and haven't been for a
while it's changing ambiguous
something's either compliant or it's not
compliant it's not something can't be
more compliant than something
else where does it say more compliant
note 4.1 the Constitution has been
amended to update and use more equality
compliant and inclusive
descriptors what page page 35
page 35 of the pack so does that mean
that the descript descriptors used in
the Constitution at the moment are not
compliant with equality
legislation 4.1 says to amend has been
amended to up key information page 35.
4.1 the Constitution has been amended to
update and use more equality and
inclusive description descript
the other changes if adopted are and
then it's 4.2 which we've just looked at
Council ward has just um yeah
amended so is it the case that the
descriptors used in the Constitution at
the moment that that that you want CH
it's proposed to have amendments in the
appendix are is is it the case that they
are not not at the moment compliant with
quality
legislation thank you chair three you
um unfortunate use of the word more
um yeah it's it's it's all about
um when when it was when it was brought
up um it was the idea was that more
inclusivity using language that had a
more equality aspect to it it's not that
none of it's not compliant with equality
act it is there there's no question
about the wording in place is it is it
compliant with the equality act what it
is but the idea was to have more and
I've used the word again more I I wrote
the that bit of the report so as I put
it in uh it was it was uh really you can
do away with the word more it it it is
compliant it was compliant it
is more compliant
now may
I thank you yes in which case why do we
need to change any if it's compliant
already we don't need any changes that
are just essentially becoming more
aligned with the fashionable ideology of
the
moment councelor mcro and then the chief
exec and then councelor Haren I think
we're missing the point here if you
don't mind my saying so chair we've got
he or she currently in the Constitution
we have chair man or chair woman we're
changing he she to they or there um
basically they covers it all he she is
another way of saying the same thing and
fundamentally arguing about which is
more PC or which isn't everybody
understands what they means he she is
Clumsy they is simpler I have no
problems with any of this and fussing
about it frankly seems beyond the point
Thank You chief executive no councelor
Haren and then I'll come back to you
councel
re yes thank you chair just for point of
clar
51 on page 51 liquidated
damages um I've been trying to figure
this out all week but I haven't slept at
all um what does it actually mean
liquidated damage I presume it's money
put up by a contractor in procurement in
case the job goes wrong or they go
bankrupt and there's over 100,000
ceiling um just some explanation please
would be appreciated actually understand
what the words mean thank
you thank you chair U liquidated damages
just means that for a specific harm if
you like rather than asking them to
complete the contract you're asking them
for
money or that bit of the contract so
that's what liquidated damages is a it's
the it's the intention actually give us
the money then and we'll get it done
elsewhere that's really why you call it
liquidated damages and that's why it's
it's good to look at each contract to
work out whether or not you want the
contract done or whether you want money
so you can get it done by somebody else
if it if it's not performed by the the
original contractor so you look at each
of the items under the contract and you
go well that we could get done somewhere
else if you can't do it so we put
liquidated damages figure on it that
actually no one else can do it only you
can do it so we want you to do it and if
you don't do it it's breach of contract
and other compensation
payable that's the reason having a
figure of
liquidated right thank you for that just
a followup so if the contractor goes
bankrupt and doesn't have any money how
would we stand then we it would be very
difficult to get the money from um a
bankrupt contractor wouldn't it I I can
see what know why this is in but it I
think you'll agree it is a bit
complicated isn't it and maybe there
would be better words um you tell
me absolutely I do agree with you the
the other way to do it then is um what
tends to happen if you've got a contract
uh for large amounts that you ask for a
bond and it's the bond that that isn't
mentioned in there that's a separate
process it's the bond that will then uh
covers usually covers 10% of the of the
overall contract and the idea is that if
if there is a default then you rely you
pull on the bond to complete the works
and to have the money to complete the
works separate from liquidated
damages so this would then be included
in the small print of each individual
contract is what you're saying is that
yes yeah okay yeah yes that's fine um I
I think everybody else needs to
understand it as well if we do go into a
contract just what's at State thank you
thank you councilor
ree chairman um although councilor mcra
um seemed to be starting the debate on
the on this question um as opposed to
answering a question um I would also
like to ask a second question that um at
the moment you you're referred to um at
the moment as Madame chairman in
subsequent um documentation is there
provision in the um in the Constitution
for us if in the event of our being
appointed to chair any commit any
committee is it provided for that we can
choose how we would wish to be addressed
as chairman or chair because quite
frankly the idea that being designated
an item of as an item of furniture as
opposed to a human being I find quite
abor and far from inclusive it's it
feels like an exclusion from the human
race I've been dealing with these
questions since about
1993 when I worked at Sterling
University and we had academics that
would didn't like the word chair
chairman but they accepted the word
woman and they accepted the word person
where the last syllable is the
Ma I have been asked how I would like to
be referred to and I don't have any
Hang-Ups I can be called the chair I can
be called chairman I can be called Madam
chair I can be called chair
whatever it just doesn't bother me
because I know who I am and I know where
I've come from and I know what I'm
doing Ian we Chang in the Constitution
will subsequent documentation refer to
the chair throughout or his chairman or
chairwoman as as requested by well it
says in the appendix that chair chairman
is being changed to chair and vice
chairman is being changed to Vice chair
yes but should there not be provision
for people to choose given that we're
asked constantly to choose our pronouns
would it not be a good idea to include
provision as an amendment that we could
add people for give people the
opportunity if they are if they are
appointed to that office to be addressed
as they and referred to in documentation
as chairman or chair person or
chairwoman or chair if indeed they do
want to be referred to as an item of
furniture it does make translations
difficult you're right councelor
beer well Madam
chairman could you just clarify for me I
always refer to a a lady in charge of
the councel as ad chairman and my plan
chairman I refer to him as Mr chairman I
have no problems with that am I going to
get into trouble for addressing you as
Madame chairman or Mr chairman not not
you Mr
chairman uh so because it's quite
confusing when you read these 10 pages
of of appendix there's so many where
they're changing it I understand what
you're saying this could be referred to
as that if they so wish but you're quite
happy to be known as madam chairman and
I hopefully my plan and chairman is
quite happy to be known as Mr chairman
when I'm addressing them thank you
councelor
mcro isn't it true that this is just a
document for reference it does not
prescribe us to call the chair any
particular title it just describes the
function we can call the chairman
whatever the chairperson man woman we're
not child obviously whatever they like
to hear and that's always been the case
it's a matter of and courtesy this is
just a document that describes the
function we shouldn't get bulked down
with this stuff thank you very much I'm
going to ask the officer to respond to
all the comments yeah thank you chair um
the wording in the Constitution doesn't
preclude chair I'm saying I would like
to be referred to as a chairperson a
chairman or a chairwoman it's just
that's just common courtesy in terms of
it's just that the paperwork and the
intention behind this was to make the
Constitution I just think about it a
little bit to make the
Constitution uh I'm going to use that
phrase again but I perhaps shouldn't
more compliant not that it wasn't in the
first place but to to just have that
thought process so it's just to think so
as a what is it as an authority that
you're saying when you make a change to
the Constitution to make the words equal
tative you're saying what that's how we
want to proceed in the future now that
you still need to Accord a chair Madam
chair Mr chair the appropriate respect
and and for any chair of any committee
um but it's just words in the
Constitution but the intention behind it
is is is a bit more than just words um
as I said at the end of the day there's
nothing in the Constitution that
prevents you from referring as councelor
mcro said referring to the chair in uh
in the fashion that they would
appreciate being um referred
to thank you can we now move on oh
councelor Jameson I didn't see your hand
hiding there um on a different
subject um on the standard procurement
scheme of Delegation could I ask why um
bids of up to 150k and not put out for
tender
yet that's not classed as the key
decision I think that's that's where
that comes
from oh right
okay everybody happy can we move to the
vote yes mam chair thank you very much
Council
beia
okay I'll now the ask the corporate
manager for
governance take us to the
vote um chair that um vote has been
changed to reflect the amendment that
Council Ward tabled at the start and
that vote is now in progress
okay
councelor Riley can I take your
vote
okay can I take your vote
manually thank
you and councelor Plum can I take your
vote
please thank
you chair that's 27 votes for that's
unanimous thank you very much now I'd
like to invite councilor Ward to
introduce paper
bc23 sl23 and to move the
recommendations in the report
the over to you Council award thank you
madam chairman um I'm not going to take
too long over this it's a very
straightforward report um we go through
this every year um and this is to agree
the timetable of our committee meetings
for the 2024 to 25 Municipal year um I
hope everyone's had a chance to look at
the dates um and if there are any issues
then we can resolve them outside of the
meeting I I don't really want to
scrutinize individual dates uh this
evening but um uh I hope that the report
meets everyone's satisfaction and I'd
like to move propos recommendations in
paragraph two of the report thank you
councelor uh councelor you're proposing
so can I have a second please councel
saw questions
anyone no we'll move to the
vote
yes thank
you
CH it's now showing in blue can I take
your vote CS before thank
you it is sorry yeah it is now it's bit
slow
chair that is 27 votes for that is
unanimous thank you very much I'll now
invite the chief executive to introduce
paper
bc23
24 thank you chairman uh as Council will
be aware and as already heard if the Ali
leaves us uh in the coming weeks as he
looks forward to retirement uh we are
however required to have a monitoring
officer every council is required to
have a monitoring officer in place we
are currently out to recruit for a
permanent monitoring officer but we will
have a period of Gap whilst we are going
through that recruitment process and so
the paper before you proposes to appoint
Jan Robinson who you will have seen
swiftly left the room uh to appoint Jan
Robinson as the interim monit monitoring
officer pending that permanent
appointment happy to take any questions
okay thank
you any
questions she's run away exactly I
wasn't going to say
that councilor Riley are you asking a
question or are you entering debate I'm
asking a question
okay inform I get right um we are
required
man for governance and Civic office fine
and we are told that the Post St is
included in sorry lost it the post is
Incorporated in the RO of director for
Law and
governance
so we have corporate manager and we have
a director are they the same you know am
I just being too
picky heaven forbid heaven forbid never
um so just for clarity so the role of
monitoring officer is an additional
statutory post similar to the role of
head ofid service and the role of
section1 Officer um and that is then
bestowed upon a council upon an officer
sorry uh by full Council so we're
proposing or I'm proposing that you
bestow that honor of being monitoring
officer or responsibility uh onto the
corporate manager in this case Janice
Robinson uh at the point that we
permanently replace the existing vacancy
that is at a director level I will come
back before you and say to you can you
now bestow that role of monitoring
officer onto the new
director thank you can I have a proposal
and then a seconder
please councelor da Derek Davis is
proposing okay and councelor McLaren
seconding are there any more questions
that need
answering do we want to enter into
debate or shall we move forward to a
vote vote thank you very
much thank you chair that vote is now
opened coun can I take
your I'm coming I'm getting there I'm
getting
sorry you having a problem your V hasn't
come through
yet that's right would you like me to
take it
B
thank you chair that's 27 votes for
that's unanimous thank you very much
thank you very much councelors I think
Henry's gone to see whether she can find
our our interim manager of governance
yeah yeah
well
congratulations
considerations well that's what the
councilors thought when they saw you
bulk for the door okay
um we now consider Council counselor
appointments
now I'll ask the leader of the
council Council award do you have any
changes yes uh Madam chairman just just
one um having looked through all of the
appointments we made at full Council and
and subsequent of that um there is just
one um appointment that we have
forgotten and that is mental health
Champion it's a role that we created um
a few years ago in the last Council um
and has remained unfilled since the
election back in May so I would like to
propose you madam chairman thank you
take that
Ro do you have a
second councelor Haram thank you does it
just put it straight to the vote we'll
put it straight to the vote yes thank
you very
much hands
up
okay motions on notice we haven't
received
any so it is 6:31 and I declare the
meeting closed and our next meeting is
Tuesday 21st of November at 5:30 thank
you very much everyone wasn't quite 45
minutes but nearly
there